madame la mini c'est avec plaisir que
nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour
évoquer la biodiversité la stratégie
nationale et diplomatique de la france
pour la préserver c'est un sujet qui
nous tient à coeur et qui constitue en
quelque sorte l'adn de notre commission
car nous sommes à double propulsion
parallèlement à l'aménagement du
territoire le développement durable est
au centre de nos préoccupations et nous
sommes vigilants à la bonne articulation
de ces deux thématiques l'érosion de la
biodiversité à l'échelle mondiale est en
effet plus que préoccupante et pbs la
plateforme intergouvernementale
scientifique et politique sur la
biodiversité et les services
écosystémiques qui constituent ce que
l'on pourrait appeler le gic de la body
de la biodiversité a alerté dans son
rapport d'octobre dernier sur les liens
entre perte de biodiversité est en débit
nous savions déjà que la biodiversité et
rendait de nombreux services à l'homme
en contribuant notamment à la diversité
de notre alimentation et à l'habilité
l'habitabilité de notre cadre vie mais
là nous prenons conscience que des
pandémies plus fréquentes pandémie
meurtrière et coûteuse adviendront si la
biodiversité continue à décroître les
experts à l'origine de ce rapport estime
que la mise en oeuvre d'une stratégie
visant à réduire les risques par la
création d'aires protégées de modes de
production et de consommation plus
durable aura un coût bien plus faible
que les épidémies qui pourrait advenir
plus que jamais il importe d'être
ambitieux la france doit s'appuyer sur
la stratégie cohérente et concertée avec
nos voisins et les autres pays car les
écosystèmes
donc que faire des frontières humaines
et les problématiques sont
transnationales ce sera d'ailleurs
l'enjeu de la cop15 sur la biodiversité
dont nous venons d'apprendre le report
qui devrait avoir lieu finalement du 11
au 24 octobre prochain un coming en
chine afin de fixer une nouvelle feuille
de route et un cadre global pour
protéger la biodiversité la présidence
française
de l'union européenne au premier
trimestre au premier semestre pardon
2022 pourrait également être un temps
fort pour faire rayonner la vision
française en la matière l'enjeu de
taille et c'est vous avec votre ministre
de tutelle qui avait notamment à
concevoir et défendre les mesures
nécessaires face à ce défi immense celui
de notre siècle
des annonces ont déjà été faites
notamment avec l'élaboration de
biodiversité 2030 la troisième stratégie
nationale pour la biodiversité afin de
préserver les écosystèmes et les espèces
notre santé et notre qualité de vie pour
les dix prochaines années
je pense également à la nouvelle
stratégie nationale pour les aires
protégées ou encore à la stratégie
nationale bas carbone
nous voyons d'un bon oeil la déclinaison
territoriale des mesures annoncées
les sénateurs sont toujours sensibles à
la prise en compte des territoires et
des élus locaux dans la définition des
politiques publiques cela m'amène à vous
poser une première série de questions
quelle est la vision que vous portez par
rapport à la nouvelle stratégie des
aires protégées
la précédente stratégie n'ayant pas
atteint ses objectifs comment comptez
vous faire pour réussir demain sur la
question des moyens
comment faire en sorte qu'une partie du
plan de relance sérieux bien à la
préservation de la biodiversité
quels nouveaux moyens humains y
consacrez vous quels sont les
engagements de votre ministère en la
matière notre commission est également
attentive au sort de la proposition de
loi tendant à réguler l'hyper
fréquentation des sites naturels et
culturels patrimoniaux nour son ancien
collègue jérôme bignon adopté par le
sénat en novembre 2019
à cet égard nous constatons non sans
plaisir la fécondité des idées portées
par notre assemblée l'esprit de nos
travaux a germé auprès de nos collègues
députés qui ont adopté un article 56 bis
au projet de loi climat qui permet au
maire ou aux préfets de réglementer ou
d'interdire accès des personnes des
véhicules et des animaux espaces
protégés
c'est également le signe un signe fort
que les mentalités évoluent les
difficultés juridiques et les réserves
qui avait alors été soulevée devant nous
semble avoir disparu c'est le signe
indéniable que l'environnement est une
cause qui a progressé y compris jusqu'au
plus haut niveau et au sein des services
du ministère de la transition écologique
madame la ministre parlons vision
globale parlons stratégie parlons moyens
humains parlant moyens financiers
l'urgence nous commande d'être ambitieux
nous vous écoutons merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les les sénateurs de m'avoir trouvé en
ce temps et cette invitation dans un
calendrier législatif qui sur nos sujets
a effectivement très très dense et très
intense en ce moment vous l'avez dit
nous vivons un moment qui est
extrêmement particulier d'abord parce
que nous savons la dégradation de la
biodiversité se poursuit à un rythme
sans précédent
les alertes sont nombreuses la situation
largement documenté aujourd'hui les
rapports de liddes vs planète vivante du
wwf nous donne des chiffres très très
alarmant les espèces protégées sont sont
extrêmement touchées la biodiversité
ordinaire l'est tout autant
et dans cette crise que nous traversons
qui est à la fois sanitaire économique
environnemental je crois que nous avons
un moment un moment particulier
également de prise de conscience qui
doit faire que les questions de
d'érosion de la biodiversité et de
préservation de l'environnement doivent
être prises je crois comme les questions
climatiques l'ont été il ya quelques
décennies maintenant et doivent trouver
toute leur place et leur force dans nos
politiques publiques avec effectivement
donc une évaluation des objectifs
d'aichi qui avait été fixé en 2010 qui
malheureusement a conclu à ce qu' aucun
des objectifs n'aient été atteint une
première évaluation de la loi
biodiversité de 2016 qui nous donne un
premier point de repère également sur la
difficulté à mettre en oeuvre et à
atteindre les objectifs que nous nous
sommes fixés dans cette réduction de
l'érosion de la biodiversité des points
particuliers qui ont pu être soulevées
le du bon usage et de la montée en
puissance de la séquence le rc nous nous
y reviendrons des dispositifs qui ont
également et des outils étaient mis en
oeuvre comme les paiements pour services
environnementaux les obligations réelles
environnementale qui trouve aujourd'hui
toute leur place
et puis des chantiers beaucoup plus
vastes comme celui du financement de la
biodiversité des politiques
environnementales d'une manière plus
générale et cette fiscalité
environnementale qu'il va sans doute
falloir revoir dans sa globalité un
périmètre donc de ce secrétariat d'état
une recréation de ce secrétariat d'état
qui est déjà un signal fort de la
volonté du gouvernement et du président
de la république de donner toute leur
place aux politiques de préservation de
la biodiversité avec un chant qui est
donc très vaste de la protection des
espaces et des espèces à la recherche le
partage de connaissances les politiques
de l'eau évidemment qui sont essentiels
l'éducation à la nature les questions de
justice de police et de droit de
l'environnement des dossiers comme la
chasse la pêche qui sont très
structurant et notamment dans les
territoires que vous représentez ici une
réflexion qui qui accompagne un débat
citoyen sur la question du bien-être
animal
les grands prédateurs
heures qui sont également des sujets qui
sont entrés dans le débat public et sont
au quotidien des défis à relever dans
les équilibres que nous devons retrouver
dans nos territoires entre la nature sa
préservation et l'activité humaine les
activités économiques qui s'y déploie
donc dans ce périmètre également un
volet international européen d'abord
communautaire et international avec l
honneur que me fait la france 2 me de
m'avoir nommé vice président au sein de
l'assemblée des nations unies pour
l'environnement en haut lieu
nous portons cette ambition cette
ambition française et cela réclame la
plus grande cohérence une cohérence
d'abord entre les politiques que nous
déployons au niveau national et ce que
nous portons au niveau international et
donc une cohérence entre les objectifs
et les moyens c'est ce que nous allons
développer aussi bien moyens humains
évidemment que financier avec des
opérateurs également les bras armé
opérationnelle du déploiement de nos
politiques
l'office français de la biodiversité à
peine plus d'un an et déjà des
démissions et un ancrage sur les
territoires une culture commune qui se
développe au sein de cet établissement
et qui est très observé aussi au niveau
international qui est très regardée et
les agences de l'eau qu'ils font
ce travail de longue date sur des
projets de territoire avec un nouveau
regard sans doute sur la gestion de
l'eau cette gestion quantitative cette
eau en tant que ressource beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui que observée au regard des
besoins et des usages donc un travail
extrêmement intense également et vous le
savez au niveau interministériel et de
décloisonnement de nos politiques
puisque cette préservation de
l'environnement elle se joue à tous les
niveaux et dans toutes les dents tous
les périmètres un travail évidemment
intense avec le ministère de la mer le
ministère de l'agriculture de
l'éducation de la santé et cette
approche one health qui est vraiment la
concrétisation de ce que nous devons à
décloisonner nos différentes politiques
un opérateur également donc en cotutelle
avec le mystère de la transition
écologique qui est l'eau nf et ce sujet
des forêts sur lequel je reviendrai qui
est également dans nos territoires
un objet est une une image une vitrine
de ce que le réchauffement climatique de
ce que les enjeux d équilibre entre
environnement impacts environnementaux
et filières économiques doivent nous
appeler à innover et à accompagner si ce
n'est à résoudre des défis liés aux
changements climatiques
avec donc des stratégies vous l'avez dit
des partenariats les différents niveaux
de collectivités
locales et territoriales l'état
évidemment il ne peut pas seul et vous
le savez nous avons cette nécessaire
cohérence à trouver entre ces
différentes politiques et ses différents
champs de compétences qui doivent nous
permettre de relever ces défis majeurs
des régions chef de file avec une
compétence d'aménagement qui vont
également déployé dans le registre des
aires protégées
ce réseau de parcs naturels régionaux
des départements qui peuvent être amenés
à financer des projets et d'aider des
compétences sur la protection des
espaces naturels sensibles
et puis ce bloc communal qui est porteur
de projet et des compétences eau
assainissement qui sont également encore
très présente dans le dans les débats
locaux c'est donc en associant ces
collectivités territoriales pleinement
que j'entends déployer différentes
stratégies
vous l'avez évoqué la stratégie
nationale aires protégées la stratégie
nationale biodiversité avec ses
différents niveaux de collectivités des
départements qui sont par exemple à
l'issue des dernières assises de la
biodiversité qui se sont positionnés au
travers d'une motion dans laquelle ils
s'engagent en faveur des aires protégées
et propose des mesures réglementaires et
des modalités de de relations locales
avec avec le fbi et pour lesquels nous
avons introduit à l'article 57 du projet
de loi climat et résilience la
possibilité du droit de préemption sur
les espaces naturels sensibles
c'était une disposition attendu donc
nous sommes heureux de résoudre cette
difficulté ce trou dans la raquette si
je puis me permettre
kim était certains départements en
difficulté et puis des partenariats
d'une contractualisation qui se
matérialise aujourd'hui avec les
contrats de relance et transition
écologique qui vont donc agrégé tous les
différents dispositifs que nous pouvions
connaître et qui avec les cpe air
deviennent vraiment la structure le
l'ossature de cette contractualisation
territoriale qui doit se dédouane se
déployer donc sur les différents volets
que l'on a plus que l'on a pu évoquer
des stratégies donc des stratégies
nationales cette stratégie des aires
protégées 2021 2030 qui a été présenté
en début d'année avec un objectif
réaffirmé de protection 30 % du
territoire terrestre et marin et de 10%
de protection forte ce qui est un
objectif très ambitieux que nous
relevons bien volontiers d'autant qu'il
doit nous amener dès 2022 atteindre des
objectifs que nous portons au niveau
international notamment au sein de la
cop 15 à horizon 2030
et puis un premier plan qui est donc d
un plan d'action qui doit décliner de
manière opérationnelle parce que des
stratégies et des visions nous en avons
connu beaucoup nous savons aujourd'hui
pour mesurer nos progrès et notre
engagement il nous faut des points de
rendez-vous et des actions concrètes
donc des plans d'action triennaux que
nous développons aussi bien sur la
stratégie r protégés que sur la
stratégie nationale biodiversité à
laquelle je vais venir dans un instant
sur cette stratégie à protéger jeu saxe
et a pu interroger différents élus je
vous propose aujourd'hui donc cette
cette contractualisation de la
matérialiser dans le cadre de chartres
est vraiment d'associer tous les niveaux
de collectivités à la définition de
nouveaux périmètres d'aires protégées
les associer à la fois dans la
définition de ces périmètres de ce choix
de surface aussi bien de création ou
d'extension mais aussi à la gestion de
césaire pour l'avoir vécu sur la
création du onzième parc national des
forêts ce sont des espaces de discussion
et des changes qui sont d'une richesse
tout à fait particulière et on réalise à
ce moment que des enjeux qui paraissent
vraiment contradictoire et en tensions
trouvent le chemin et construisent
vraiment
un chemin commun aux bénéfices évidents
de tous les territoires puisque à la
fois les sphères économiques
touristiques et en terme de paysage et
de fierté de nos territoires
tous ces enjeux se retrouve dans la
définition de ses projets communs donc
des chartes de territorialisation qui
pourront être être mises en place
localement denses et dans cette
définition de périmètres d'aires
protégées et de et de gestion de ces
heurts et puis ce volet reprotéger qui
s'inscrit dans une stratégie nationale
biodiversité 2021 sera l'année de la
réécriture de cette stratégie décennale
avec à nouveau des plans d'action
triennaux dédié et une volonté
d'associer plus que d'associer
d'ailleurs de partir des territoires
je ne vous cache pas que dans la façon
de faire c'est la puce cela a pu
dérouter d'autant que nous nous trouvons
dans un calendrier qui est également
très resserrée mais j'ai vraiment
souhaité que nous partions des régions
et donc je fais actuellement une tournée
des régions de france en participant aux
comités régionaux biodiversité avec tous
les acteurs des différentes régions
d'abord à un bilan à une photographie de
l'existence sur les différents
territoires
et puis à ce que chaque région puisse
participer apporter une contribution à
cette stratégie nationale biodiversité
ces différentes contributions elles
constitueront le matériau qui sera
soumis à réflexion aux instances
nationales
c'est donc un renversement de la
construction de cette stratégie que l'on
pouvait connaître plutôt descendante et
partant d'experts par l'expérience par
le retour de terrain et deux des acteurs
qui au quotidien met en oeuvre nos
politiques donc une stratégie qui part
des régions qui
sera proposé aux instances nationales
dans le même temps une concept d'une
concertation une consultation citoyenne
un travail intense d'interministérialité
à sion avec un comité interministériel
qui doit vraiment accompagner les choix
qui seront faits et qui seront inscrits
dans cette stratégie pour la renforcer
et un outil un site internet dont je
vous annonce la mise en ligne dans les
heures qui viennent
biodiversité point gouv.fr donc une
nouvelle plate forme sur laquelle nous
avons voulu rassembler toutes les
ressources concernant la biodiversité
mais différents liens des différents un
socle de connaissances et sur lequel
vous pourrez soit en tant que
qu'individu soit en tant que collectif
associations et élus société civile
organisée déposer des contributions à
cette stratégie nationale biodiversité
donc nous avons ce dispositif qui doit
nous amener à une présentation d'une
vedero du texte de la stratégie
nationale lors de 8 cm que nous
prendrons encore la liberté d'amendé sur
le volet international à l'issue de la
cop15 pour une présentation de la
nouvelle stratégie à la toute fin 2001
terrain où tout début 2022
et puis une autre stratégie
à laquelle j'ai eu à coeur de m'atteler
dès mon arrivée à ce secrétariat d'état
c'est la stratégie nationale
déforestation apporté puisque nous le
savons nous avons des leviers énorme
d'action nous ne pouvons pas détourner
le regard
ne serait-ce que l'achat public peut
concerner 10 % du pib et impacts on le
sait malheureusement la déforestation à
l'autre bout du monde
donc nous avons mis en place également
une plateforme qui va permettre à la
fois aux acheteurs aux consommateurs de
vérifier leur approvisionnement et de
vérifier qu'ils n'impactent pas à
l'autre bout du monde la déforestation
nous avons pour cela besoin de données
douanières et une disposition a été
introduite à nouveau projet de loi
climat résilience qui nous permettent
d'utiliser les données douanières pour
les croiser avec les données
satellitaires et pouvoir vérifier cette
filière d'approvisionnement un
accompagnement évident en terme d' aide
au développement dans les pays
producteurs à l'évolution de filière
plus durable un guide de l'achat public
zéro déforestation dont je fais la
promotion de ma tournée des régions et
que je vous incite auprès de chaque élu
et collectivités à faire également le
la promotion puisque on l'a dit ce sont
potentiellement 10 % du pib qui sont
concernés par cet achat public sur
lequel nous avons donc un gros levier
d'action cette fantaisie d'ailleurs
nationale déforestation à porter elle
trouvera un écho et un développement au
niveau européen et cela sera un des uns
des gros dossiers portés lors de la
présidence française début 2022
des espaces donc des pratiques et des
opérateurs pour mettre en oeuvre
concrètement nos politiques l'office
français de la biodiversité les agences
de l'eau un office français dont on l'a
dit la création début janvier 2020 est
toute récente de 1600 agents un budget
de 516 millions d'euros avec donc un
outil performant et au plus près du
terrain et des territoires avec un
budget supplémentaire de 85 millions
d'euros au titre du plan de relance qui
va permettre à l'office de la
biodiversité de développer des projets
de l'accompagner par la voie d'appels à
projets de nouveaux développements y
compris en outre-mer avec un volet sur
l'eau potable et l'assainissement
nous avons également donc un travaille
actuellement sur le contrat d'objectifs
et de performance de l'office français
de la biodiversité qui doit aboutir
courant 2021 et une stabilisation des
effectifs c'était une inquiétude
grâce à un arbitrage qui doit nous
permettre de nous permettre de monter en
puissance notamment avec 20 atp qui ont
pu être que j'ai pu annoncer très
récemment qu'ils vont venir abonder les
parcs naturels marins en regard de 20
autres tp pour les parcs nationaux une
politique de l'eau également don qui est
développé par les agences de l'eau sur
la base d'une feuille de route des
assises de l'eau de 2019 avec nous le
savons un travail à l'oeuvre sur les
projets territoriaux de la gestion de
l'eau les
me péter ge qui sont en émergence et qui
doivent nous permettre de réconcilier
ces enjeux entre usage besoin notamment
du monde agricole besoins en eau potable
est une ressource qui malheureusement
tend à s'amenuiser donc une gestion de
cette ressource qui doit être la plus la
plus harmonieuse et raisonnée possible
des agences qui accompagne donc
techniquement et financièrement les
territoires danser dans ses démarches
avec une mission d'appui qui vient
d'être constitué et d'inspecteurs
généraux pour généraux pour faciliter
ces projets un cadre réglementaire
nationale qui doit sécuriser les
décisions qui sont prises par les
préfets en la matière notamment en
matière de gestion quantitative avec
l'envoi du décret du même nom cette
semaine au conseil d'état pour un
dernier examen et je sais que ce décret
était extrêmement attendu pour sécuriser
certaines décisions
et puis une politique de l'eau qui se
développe aussi via la qualité de nos
rivières de nos ressources souterraines
des moyens également dans le plan de
relance donc de hauteur de 250 millions
d'euros pour financer ses projets
d'amélioration de l'assainissement et de
production d'eau potable donc des moyens
sans précédent qu'ils doivent nous
permettre d'intervenir sur une meilleure
connaissance également deux de nos
réseaux avec une enveloppe également de
47 millions d'euros
sur le plan aux autres maires qui
s'ajoutent aux 2,1 milliards d'euros
chaque année de redevances affectés aux
agences de l'eau donc des moyens
importants pour des enjeux considérables
des acteurs des acteurs qui agissent au
quotidien au sein des agences de l'eau
une politique de continuité portés par
les collectivités et les fédérations de
pêche que je souhaite saluer dans ce
travail sur le terrain au quotidien qui
sont à nos yeux aussi et cette vigilance
qu'ils peuvent avoir
nous nous accompagnent dans le
développement de ces de ces politiques
et d'ailleurs il
voie et nous le voyons quand on rétablit
cc continuité on voit revenir des
espèces en pense au saumon à l'anguille
là où elles avaient disparu et ce sont
des signes assez rassurant de ce que
quand nous intervenons quand nous ré
intervenant pour rétablir ces
continuités écologiques
la nature reprend ses droits donc des
pêcheurs qui sont au quotidien nos ali
sur le terrain et je salue leur travail
la forêt également et cette bonne
hiérarchie des des usages du bois qui
apporte une contribution déterminante à
nos politiques qu'il est urgent et vital
de sécuriser les forêts qui sont
gravement fragilisé par le changement
climatique et nous avons exactement
nous avons des défis et à cet égard le
parc national des forêts sera une des
vitrines d'expérimentation de cette
forêt a les preuves du réchauffement
climatique de 7,7 politique sur les
écosystèmes et les enjeux socio
économiques dans les territoires qui
sont rendus par la forêt et au travers
d'une production durable de bois qui est
soutenu à nouveau dans le cadre du plan
de relance à hauteur de 200 millions
pour le renouvellement forestier avec
cet enjeu de diversification des
sylviculture et des essences et puis
l'eau nf1 opérateurs donc en co tutelle
du ministère de la transition écologique
et du ministère de l'agriculture qui
connaît des inquiétudes pour lesquelles
nous faut inventer des solutions
pérennes stabiliser le financement
un établissement qui doit évidemment se
consacrer en priorité à la gestion
durable adaptatif de nos forêts
publiques
nous signerons un contrat d'objectif
robuste avant l'été 2021 et sans
attendre le mystère de la transition
écologique a augmenté ses financements à
l'office national de la forêt de 9,2
millions d'euros dès 2021 pour renforcer
ses missions d'intérêt général
d'autres chantiers sont présents et à
venir
un gros dossier de ce secrétariat d'état
est également celui de la chasse et en
tant que représentant des territoires je
ne vous l'apprends pas nous avons
effectivement un patrimoine qui
s'exprime dans les territoires des
dossiers tels que celui des dégâts de
gibier qui doivent trouver des réponses
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs sont
extrêmement impacté par des populations
de grands gibiers notamment de sangliers
et cervidés qui impacte réellement les
cultures donc un groupe de travail que
j'avais souhaité et qui entre
agriculteurs et chasseurs à formuler des
propositions sur lesquelles il nous
incombe aujourd'hui de statuer puisque
les incidents ce ne sont pas moins que
ce soit au niveau réglementaire mais
parfois aussi législatif
et puis un modèle économique en termes
de dédommagement de c2c dégâts qu'il
convient de revoir avec donc un un
groupe de travail pour lesquelles nous
apporteront sans tarder des des réponses
et des arbitrages
la question de la sécurité à la chasse
qui malheureusement
dans l'actualité nous rappelle
trop souvent à des à la nécessaire prise
en compte des dispositions qui existent
sur la prise en compte de la sécurité
dans ces pratiques
un cadre qui existe sur cette cette mise
en oeuvre et ce respect visant le zéro
accident nous avons effectivement encore
à travailler sans doute aussi sur des
questions d'information information des
riverains formation des autres usagers
de la nature pour apaiser apaiser ces
questions sur lesquelles effectivement
une une violence se se développent et je
m'en inquiète je m'en vais me et je
pense que nous avons tout ça sans doute
à accepter que ce débat ait lieu pour
pour que chacun retrouve sa place dans c
dans ces territoires et dans ces espaces
de nature sans que sans que des craintes
ou ou une agressivité se développe avec
également donc la notion de gestion
adaptative des espèces qui m'est cher
vous vous en doutez et ccga ces comités
d'experts de la gestion adaptative donc
un outil récent qui doit sans doute
trouvé certaines certaines améliorations
et qui pour autant demeure il me semble
un outil réel d'apaisement
d'objectivation scientifique de ces
populations est de et de ses possibles
en terme de pratique en équilibre avec
la nature et les espèces donc un outil
que j'entends vraiment
renforcer et accompagner tant que tant
que de besoin et puis une politique qui
s'exprime évidemment dans la mer et nos
océans avec la france qui possède la
seconde zone économique exclusive
mondiale donc un rôle capital de ces
océans pour lesquels nous avons une
action aussi bien nationales
qu'internationales un caractère souvent
irréversibles des dommages causés à
l'environnement qui nous ont appelés on
l'a évoqué a travaillé sur les questions
de police de justice et de droit de
l'environnement le parquet européen et
la justice pénale spécialisé vous a
amené je vous en remercie a voté la
création de ces pôles régionaux
spécialisés donc près chaque cour
d'appel qui vont permettre vraiment de
prendre en compte ces c'est ces dossiers
une convention judiciaire économique
ainsi créé qui va permettre aussi la
résolution de certains contentieux
certaines situations en gagnant en
rapidité pour pouvoir intervenir le plus
rapidement possible de nouvelles
compétences et prérogatives de police
judiciaire pour les officiers
judiciaires de l'environnement qui vont
leur permettre de mener des enquêtes de
bout en bout et de ne plus être
tributaire de de compétences restrictive
de la constatation jusqu'à l'audition à
d'éventuels perquisitions et je tiens à
remercier à cet égard le général
rodriguez dggn qui nous a permis dans
une réflexion avec le fbi et l'oclaesp
de d'améliorer ses compétences pour les
agents de l'environnement une échelle
des peines également et la création des
délits des causses idée de mise en
danger de l'environnement qui sont
encore à l'étude et je sais que vous
aurez tout loisir de l'est de les
observer dans le cadre de l'examen du
projet de loi
emma résilience
je m'excuse de vous interrompez mais
c'était la prescience à didier mandelli
parce que j'ai un échange téléphonique
avec le ministère des finances est 19h30
et donc je voudrais pas louper cet
échange
voilà merci c'est intéressant si la
filière bois quelque chose de très très
important pour nos territoires et puis
pour notre environnement
merci monsieur le président jallet
abordé justement la question des moyens
des moyens humains et financiers
financier d'abord puisque dès le projet
de loi de finances pour 2021
vous avez bien voulu voter une
augmentation sans précédent des moyens
du ministère de la transition écologique
mais surtout pour ce qui m'occupe des
moyens dédiés à la biodiversité avec
donc une enveloppe considérablement
augmenté de 28,5 millions d'euros une
augmentation portait donc sur l'adoption
de nouvelles mesures pour les aires
protégées en matière d'investissements
dans les parcs nationaux sur la
biodiversité en forêt une hausse de la
dotation de 10 millions d'euros pour
l'office français de la biodiversité un
renforcement d'un million d'euros sur
les mesures de cohabitation entre les
grands prédateurs et pour le
pastoralisme et puis un plan de relance
évidemment qui consacre également des
budgets sans précédent 300 millions pour
l'eau 250 millions pour la biodiversité
un détail que que vous connaissez sur
les restauration écologique les aires
protégées la protection du littoral ou
encore le renforcement des barrages
autant d'opérations qui était utile et
indispensable et sur lesquels nous
allons pouvoir accélérer massivement
tout en donnant du travail aussi aux
entreprises françaises et aux opérateurs
donc à une dimension économique dans
cette transition écologique qui doit
accompagner
la mutation de notre économie et
l'accompagnement dans cette période
difficile
et puis effectivement des moyens
financiers da qui serait bien vains sans
moyens humains pour les mettre en oeuvre
et c'est une priorité
cette préservation de l'environnement
qui a été entendu par le président de la
république et par le gouvernement
puisque j'ai pu annoncer donc il y a
quelques semaines maintenant 40 tp
supplémentaires dédiés aux politiques
environnementales et aux opérateurs de
l'état en matière de biodiversité 20 atp
pour les parcs nationaux et vince de tp
pour les parcs naturels marins qui
permettront du côté des parcs nationaux
d'abonder la montée en puissance du parc
national des forêts est de redonner
quelques tpe au parc ancien plus anciens
et existants et puis des parcs naturels
marins qui effectivement souffrait aussi
d'un d'un besoin de forces vives et de
de moyens humains donc des moyens
humains financiers qui doivent
accompagner ses fortes ambitions dans un
moment on l'a dit sans précédent de
prise de conscience avec des événements
nationaux et internationaux qui doivent
porter notre ambition le congrès mondial
pour la nature de lui scène du 3 au 11
septembre à marseille le cop15 on l'a
dit biodiversité donc accueil ming en
chine du 11 au 24 octobre au niveau
européen la perspective de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
dans le premier semestre 2022 moment
dans lequel nous devrons d'abord être
irréprochable et je ne vous cache pas
avoir un certain nombre de contentieux à
travailler et à régler d'ici à cette
présidence française et ce moment sans
précédent qui nous amène vraiment à
renforcer si ce n'est à repenser nos
partenariats à nouveau l'état ne peut
rien seuls les différents niveaux de
collectivités
les différents acteurs y compris la
sphère économique qui demande
aujourd'hui à s'investir dans cette
politique et dans ces enjeux de
préservation de
la nature notre action commune ce sera
la seule garante de l'atteinte de nos
objectifs et nous permettra de relever
ces défis sans précédent et je vous
remercie pour votre travail en ce sens
et votre attention
merci madame la ministre pour cette
présentation assez exhaustive à la fois
des enjeux
évidemment que nous dont nous sommes
conscients que nous pouvons évidemment
partagé et puis également pour les
actions engagées par votre ministère à
quelques semaines effectivement de
l'examen du projet de loi climat
résilience ici au sénat je vais décida
parole dans un premier temps à guillaume
chevrollier rapporteur sur sur le budget
concernant la biodiversité
merci monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état merci pour votre
intervention vous avez effectivement
abordé de très nombreux sujets et on
voit que ô combien la biodiversité est
au coeur de beaucoup de préoccupation
aujourd'hui la santé unique autour de
l'eau le changement climatique et puis
les grands rendez vous internationaux le
congrès mondial pour la nature la cop15
donc beaucoup de questions sur la
stratégie de la france pour ce rendez
vous international et quelles ambitions
et vous en avait déjà parlé
moi je vais réagir sur vous avez évoqué
les obligations réelles environnementale
un sujet qui m'est chère fait un certain
nombre de questions écrites sur le sujet
c'est quand même un sujet qui peine à
démarrer
donc vous vous l'évoquez comment faire
en sorte quand même ça puisse réellement
être opérationnel et qui est une vraie
montée en puissance des obligations
réelles environnemental mais également
la question de
de la mise en oeuvre de la stratégie
nationale pour les aires protégées que
nous suivons de près au sein de cette
commission et notamment sur la mise en å
ddr2 sous protection forte et vous avez
parlé de chartes de territorialisation
que c'est le moyen de c'est le sens de
ma question comment vous allez associés
les territoires la définition des
objectifs et il a mise en oeuvre aussi
tout à fait opérationnel
donc ça passe par la charte est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus et est sûre sur la mise en oeuvre
avec avec quels moyens et il ya un autre
sujet que je voulais aborder que vous
avez aussi évoqué ses seins le sujet
important de la lutte contre la
déforestation importés et fait état du
lancement de la plateforme
quelle action vous préconisez de mener
pour y parvenir et avec quels
financements et est-ce que vous
travaillez à un étiquetage des produits
qui est un sujet d'une consommation
importante
et puis en dernier lieu sur le projet de
loi constitutionnelle je suis rapporteur
pour avis on a déjà eu tout à l'heure
l'audition du garde des sceaux est
aujourd'hui dans la constitution yal
terme biodiversité et là on introduit le
terme de diversité biologique pour le
garde des sceaux nous dit que en fait
c'est signé alors pourquoi pourquoi dans
un même texte constitutionnel on aurait
deux termes différents il faut peut-être
mettre une
pour une saine lecture et avoir un 8-1
unitaire danse à s'accorder sur
biodiversité ou diversité biologique
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur le sujet
et je vous prie de m'excuser parce que
je pourrais pas suivre en direct votre
réponse mais je la suivrai en visio
parce que je dois vous quitter
merci merci la ministre alors sur la
snvi très directement puisque ce sont
des outils effectivement que nous nous
déployons cette plateforme elle
nécessitait notre accès d'abord aux
données douanières et c'était un enjeu
important pour des raisons de
confidentialité vous imaginez bien de
danone
mise à sion des données donc nous
trouvons aujourd'hui ce accord avec les
différents services fiscaux et douaniers
pour faire utiliser ces informations
nous avons effectivement développé un
atelier un groupe de travail pour
l'instant sur les labels parce que
effectivement les consommateurs ont
besoin de points de repère et de pouvoir
immédiatement identifié ses besoins et
puis on fonctionne aussi avec un travail
par filière la filière du soja s'est
engagé massivement il y a quelques mois
pour une transparence sur ses
approvisionnements et le travail se
poursuit aujourd'hui avec la filière du
chocolat ce sont donc des des produits
de grande consommation qui concerne un
grand nombre de nos concitoyens et dans
des volumes importants
donc à partir moment où toute la filière
et les filières au niveau national ce
s'organisent pour vraiment faire cette
transparence sur leur politique d'achat
et d'approvisionnement
on obtient des résultats tout de suite
très conséquent cette snvi donc elle se
développe aussi avec un mécanisme d'
alerte qui va être mis à disposition des
entreprises qui le souhaitent en
fonction de leur approvisionnement et
nous avons ainsi différents dispositifs
qui doivent permettre de de signaler des
risques de déforestation liée à ces
filières sur la stratégie aires
protégées et la possibilité de cette
territorialisation alors nous avons déjà
rentrer dans le dans le code de
l'environnement
un article r 332,2 qui invite les
préfets à consulter les collectivités
territoriales dans le territoire serait
affecté par un projet de classement ou
en zone de montagne comité de massif une
zone maritime qui invite donc à avoir
cette concertation et cette consultation
des élus moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
aille plus loin
pour ceux d'entre vous qui aurait connu
c'est
ces concertations dans le cadre d'une
écriture de chartes par exemple pour un
parc national
nous avons effectivement un enjeu à
embarquer les différents acteurs et les
niveaux de collectivités dans la
construction même de ces projets donc
ces chartes elles vont se constituer sur
des territoires et des projets pré
déterminée pour nous permettre de de
vraiment associer dès le projet de
création ou d'extension d'une aire
protégée associer les différents acteurs
et ni véreux et différents niveaux de
collectivités
sur la question de la diversité
biologique dont il semblerait qu'il ne
soit question que de sémantique pur
effectivement biodiversité la
biodiversité répond à la diversité
biologique au niveau international
d'ailleurs vous connaissez la cdb qui le
définit ainsi nous avons donc depuis
depuis rio en 92 un même nom qui est
utilisé par là par la convention ou au
niveau international c'est un repère
donc je pense qu'effectivement par souci
de clarification et peut-être pour ne
pas faire un abrégé dans le terme
biodiversité la diversité biologique est
un terme plus consacré et plus juridique
sur la question des des eaux et reçus
sur laquelle je vous rejoins nous devons
absolument même journée avoir
une nous devons accompagner cette cette
montée en puissance
il ya déjà un souci de communication je
crois avoir sur l'existence même de ces
de ceux de ce format les les acteurs
s'en saisissent et on a une montée en
puissance je sais pas si on a des
chiffres aujourd'hui mais en tout cas je
je voulais transmet très volontiers par
écrit donc depuis cette loi de 2016 un
engouement qui ne se dément pas et la
loi de finances a déjà prévu des mesures
fiscales pour renforcer l'incitation à
se saisir de de cet outil avec un
rapport qui devrait nous être remis sous
peu puisque nous avons 29 au héros qui
seront six qui ont été signés en 2019 et
beaucoup de projets en cours et à
l'étude
je fais le tour
merci alors je vais donner dans l'ordre
la parole à
donc martha de cidre avec jean-paul
prince angèle préville eric gold evelyne
perron artificielle et ronan dantec
donc je vous demande de allah de limiter
à une mini 30 maxi la question fait un
gros effort de synthèse que 5 d'entre
nous d'entre vous doivent partir avant
20h15 donc relation si on veut
concentrer avoir le temps d'écouter les
réponses dans de bonnes conditions sans
avoir un désert dans la salle ce serait
parfait voilà nous y allons merci merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
vous avez déjà évoqué la lutte contre la
déforestation importés et notre collègue
guillaume chevrollier vous interrogé
là-dessus
moi je voudrais vous vous interrogez
aussi sur la forêt mais de façon un peu
plus générale de nombreux rapports ont
été publiés sur le sujet comme le
rapport de notre collègue anne catherine
loisier de 2019 que vous connaissez sans
doute et en tant que sénatrice des
yvelines où la forêt couvre 30% du
département je sais combien les forêts
sont longe des années actuelles et à
venir en fait les forêts sont un
avantage dans notre lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique puisque ces
espaces présents de nombreux atouts
puits carbone richesse et préservation
de la biodiversité filtration des sols
notamment l'inra est d'ailleurs mis en
avant l'importance de la forêt dans son
rapport de novembre 2020 sur le
potentiel de stockage de carbone dans
les sols en france pourtant c'est un
sujet qui est faiblement évoqués dans le
projet de loi climat et résilience
évidemment plusieurs mesures relèvent du
réglementaire et d'une vision plus
stratégique mais des questions comme
l'avenir de l'eau nf et les aménités
écologiques ont toute leur place dans
les discussions parlementaires qui
auront lieu sur ce texte
donc ma question madame la mini c'est
est ce que le gouvernement envisage
d'intégrer cette question à l'occasion
des débats sur le projet de loi climat
et résilience parce que ça nous semble
malgré tout important et pas uniquement
à travers le sujet de la déforestation
importés et quelle place aura la forêt
dans la stratégie nationale de la bio
diversité qui sera révisé cette année je
vous remercie merci madame lamia madame
la ministre merci pour cette
présentation exhaustive effectivement en
janvier vous avez présenté une stratégie
nationale de protection de
l'environnement
si conserver la biodiversité les sites
naturels remarquables de notre pays est
une nécessité
envisagez l'environnement sous le seul
angle de la protection de la nature de
la main de l'homme me semble tout à fait
insuffisant et conduit à considérer de
manière systématiquement négative
l'ensemble des activités des hommes
qu'elles soient économiques de
construction ou d'aménagement qui sont
pourtant un facteur de prospérité
d'amélioration du confort de nos
concitoyens je veux prendre pour exemple
la manière dont est appliqué le principe
de continuité écologique des cours d'eau
apparu dans le droit européen en 2000
transposer dans le droit national
ce principe a eu pour conséquence de
permettre la destruction de nombreux
barrages et moulins effectué depuis 2020
sur simple déclaration
cela se produit fréquemment dans mon
département où les moulins et barrages
sont détruits parfois pour un gain
environnemental très discutable ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait clarifier
l'articulation entre préservation des
milieux naturels et activités humaines
et réaffirmé que ces derniers ont
également leur place sur le territoire
et comme l'état ne peut rien seul comme
vous avez dit écoutez les et du terrain
merci angem merci monsieur le président
merci madame la ministre pour votre
exposé avec force détails alors première
question sur les aires protégées
donc comment va-t-on faire puisque on a
en protection forte actuellement 1,1
pour cent seulement et qu'on devrait
passer à 10% alors c'était prévu
initialement en 2022 dont visiblement
jusqu'en 2030 mais ça va être un travail
considérable puisque c'est quasiment la
multiplication par six de ce qu'on a
actuellement
donc comment comptez vous faire deuxième
chose sur la stratégie nationale sur la
déforestation importés qui repose
en partie en grande partie sur des
engagements volontaires qui sont peu
contraignant est-ce qu' il ne serait pas
bon peut-être des parce que les effets
sont ravageurs et comme vous avez
rappelé et l'europe est responsable du
tiers de la déforestation mondiale
pour ce qui concerne ses importations
donc est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas aller
quelque part un petit peu plus vite
et parce que l'on sait très bien que les
engagements volontaires prennent
toujours beaucoup de temps après vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez
ensuite sur le sauf que vous avez
mentionné sur l'office français de la
biodiversité qui proposait des appels à
projets alors moi je m'interroge
toujours sur l'efficacité des appels à
projets et notamment ce qui ne serait
pas intéressant
déjà parce qu'on sait que de la
biodiversité c'est seraient concernés
enfin concernera tout le territoire
national
c'est à dire de partager un peu plus
l'argent puisque on sait qu'il ya des
territoires qui seront pas s'organiser
pour répondre à ses appels à projets et
donc on va avoir des poches où on n'aura
pas exactement fait ce qu'il aurait
fallu faire concernant la biodiversité
peut-être à partager un petit peu plus
les moyens enfin les moyens financiers
pour tous les territoires
et enfin dernière chose et ça ne vous
étonnera pas sûr par rapport à la
pollution plastique est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas impulsé de manière très
forte
un traité international ou européen ou à
minima sur la méditerranée pour qu'on
puisse se mettre en accord avec tous les
pays par exemple qui sont au bord de la
méditerranée pour prendre des
engagements pour permettre de lutter
très efficacement sur la pollution
plastique au moins pour pour notre mère
médias
merci président madame la ministre
si l'origine de la pandémie actuelle
interroge d'autres dysfonctionnements
sont aussi à prendre en compte avec la
présence de nombreuses espèces invasives
sur notre territoire
alors après vos propos mama ministre le
sujet va vous paraître certainement
léger mais je vais vous parler de du
frelon asiatique qui a paru depuis 15
ans en france et qui est présent
maintenant sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
chaque année à cette époque de nouvelles
colonies apparaissent et font peser des
menaces notamment sur les ruchers alors
ce constat qui se répète à chaque
printemps montre qu'il n'y a pas de
méthode efficace pour contrôler la
prolifération d'espèces mais s'il n'y a
pas de méthode efficace constaté il n'ya
pas non plus de stratégie collective de
prévention de surveillance et de lutte
afin de réduire son impact notamment sur
les colonies d'abeilles
alors au delà du financement de la
recherche yat-il les actions concrètes
non impactant que d'autres espèces qui
peuvent être mises en place dans une
stratégie de lutte globale et cohérente
une stratégie qui dépasse le périmètre
de notre pays ou alors doit-on se
résigner au fait que le combat est déjà
perdue d'avancé
très bien evelyne qui est en visio face
à nous oui merci madame la ministre
madame la ministre
j'étais ravie de vous entendre parler
avec tant d'enthousiasmé numérique tous
les objectifs
mais dans ce contexte qui va faire
évoluer et changer les donnes
comment vont d'avancé les pnr qui sont
en révision de charte
vous savez que c'est un travail énorme
et que la chasse est aussi un outil au
service de l'environnement et ce second
texte actuel m'inquiète
merci oui merci monsieur le président
merci madame la ministre de cette
présentation
ma question est simple je partage
beaucoup de vos propos que je trouve
vertueux sur l'environnement sur la
biodiversité et beaucoup des objectifs
que
que vous nous donnez qui sont très
ambitieux mais j'ai beaucoup
d'inquiétude sur la mise en oeuvre et en
particulier sur les moyens humains et
sur les compétences pour mettre en
oeuvre ses objectifs je garde en mémoire
le travail qu'avait fait mon groupe
politique lors de la 2 lors du projet de
loi de finances sur la perte en
personnel du ministère de l'écologie
qu'ils avaient comme mon groupe avait
chiffré à une perte de 4000 e tp
équivalents temps plein dans des
organismes aussi divers que l'office
français de la biodiversité l' agence de
l'eau météo-france l'hygiène le serema
des organismes qui sont très importants
dans le quotidien j'allais dire d'eux
des questions que vous évoquez c'est
cette perte d'effectifs n'est pas
compensée loin de là par les 40 e tp que
vous annoncez sur les aires marines
protégées également sur les parcs
alors comment allez-vous faire très
concrètement par ailleurs pour rejoindre
le questionnement de madame préville
parler de la stratégie nationale de la
déforestation importés en disant que ben
oui encore une fois les objectifs sont
très intéressants je les partage
mais je me dis que en se basant
uniquement sur la bonne volonté des
industriels eh bien voilà ça suscite
beaucoup de doutes de ma part et je
pense que les obligations pourraient
avoir sans doute plus d'efficacité
enfin ce sera le dernier point sur le
pgl climat ce que vous ne trouvez pas
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de mesures sur
la bio diversité
merci
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre dans l'est dans les points
absolument essentiel pour stopper la
perte de biodiversité en france puisque
je rappelle que le bilan à la fin de
cette stratégie nationale n'est pas bon
aujourd'hui qu'on est toujours en perte
de biodiversité en france on sait qu'un
des enjeux majeurs
ça va être d'avoir une stratégie
foncière cohérente à la chaîne nationale
on parle effectivement de l'augmentation
des aires protégées mais c'est ya pas
que ça il faut que césaire soit en
contact les unes avec des autres il faut
arrêter là font attention ddd milieu et
il faut donc une stratégie totalement
cohérent l'avantagent qu'on a pour la
prochaine stratégie 2020 2030 c'est
qu'on peut s'appuyer sur des outils de
planification nouveaux que sont
notamment les estrades est puisque
effectivement sans la mobilisation des
collectivités territoriales on ne peut
pas atteindre les objectifs donc ma
question est de savoir si vous avez
prévu dans le cadre de la préparation de
cette nouvelle stratégie nationale de
débouchés véritablement sur des
cartographies qu'ils soient des
cartographies cohérente et pertinente
pour avoir un fonctionnement de
l'écosystème naturel français qui soit
satisfaisant parce que cette
fragmentation des milieux qu'on avait
mis en évidence dans leur âme dans la
commission d' enquête sur les mesures
compensatoires liés aux infrastructures
fait partie des enjeux et si on a des
aires protégées qui augmente mais qui ne
sont pas en lien les unes avec d autres
en tirera pas les objectifs donc et
peut-être du coup vous pouvez peut-être
nous redonner aussi le calendrier pour
l'adoption de la nouvelle stratégie
nationale
voilà merci à la fois pour la pertinence
et la concision de vos questions et je
laisse tout de suite un à la ministre y
répondre
merci effectivement pour la richesse de
toutes ces questions d'abord sur la
forêt et la place de la forêt on le voit
malheureusement il nous faudra beaucoup
plus que quelques heures minutes pour
aborder tous les aspects que recouvre à
la fois cette gestion 7 cette vision de
la sylviculture 7 sylviculture qui est
impactée par le réchauffement climatique
parler les parasites cette filière bois
qui a aussi tout un modèle à
reconsidérer et à valoriser dans un dans
un système commercial international et
malheureusement nous sommes souvent
interpellée sur certaines aberrations de
liés à ces usages qui se sont installés
moi je suis d'avis que cette réflexion
de la forêt elle doit avoir toute sa
place et on a également un gros volet
interministériel vous imaginez bien
qu'avec le ministère de l'agriculture on
a beaucoup à se dire et beaucoup à
travailler ensemble on a des outils
aujourd'hui je pense aux rapports quatre
lots récemment et et ceux qui l'ont
précédé qui doivent éclairer le chemin
je pense vraiment que cette réflexion
sur la forêt moi je me serais pas dire
satisfaits de quelques éléments dans un
texte projet de loi climat résilience où
on a déjà beaucoup de la profusion je
crois de thèmes avec effectivement des
accroches à la fois en termes de
filières sur des volets économiques qui
sont extrêmement importants dans les
territoires et des questions très
environnementale en tant que puits de
carbone que poumon et est que que enjeu
même de notre
résilience au changement climatique donc
je milite je vous le dis je j'ignore
encore le calendrier qui pourra
s'appliquer mais je milite pour vraiment
une
une réflexion en tant que tel et globale
sur les enjeux liés à la forêt et sa
place peut-être dans le dans la
construction de nos périmètres à la fois
ministériels et en termes de commissions
on le voit aussi bien l'assemblée
nationale qu'au sénat entre les
commissions à t d d d d athées pour
l'assemblée les commissions des affaires
économiques on a différents aussi niveau
de discussion à avoir parce qu'il nous
faut aujourd'hui une action forte et
concertée sur la question de la
stratégie nationale biodiversité
évidemment la forêt il y aura toute sa
place et j'espère préfigurer cette ce
travail au sein de nos réflexions sur la
stratégie nationale biodiversité
à la question de monsieur prince sur les
continuités et écologiques et les cours
d'eau d'abord je rappelle que rétablir
ces continuités écologiques sur les
moulins puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit
ça ne concerne pas le patrimoine bâti du
moulin en lui-même - auquel nous sommes
tous très attachés en tant que
patrimoine il faut pas qu'il ait de
confusion c'est vrai parfois pour le
pour le grand public il ya un raccourci
malheureux qui est qui est fait il
s'agit vraiment de s'attacher au seuil
du moulin et
et on a je crois des solutions en termes
de génie écologique beaucoup
d'ingéniosité pour pour trouver des
réponses en tout cas elles sont à
l'oeuvre
je crois qu'on a suffisamment dangereux
à la fois en termes de biodiversité de
bon état du patrimoine et même d' enjeu
énergétique qui qui appelle notre
ascension sur ce sur ce sujet pour que
nous nous avancions sereinement sur
c'est sur ces questions sur la sur les
aires protégées en réponse en jet
préville et sur les moyens les ambitions
déjà de la france où l'avait dit la
marche est haute notamment en termes de
protection forte et c'est l'occasion
pour moi aussi de rappeler cette
définition de la protection à la
française nous ne sommes pas plus
peut-être dans cette vision de mise sous
cloche comme on peut le connaître
ailleurs au niveau international d'une
protection stricte qui empêcherait toute
activité humaine
on est vraiment il me semble dans un
enjeu de réconciliation des activités
humaines dans leur environnement et
d'accompagnement de ses activités vers
une transition quand certaines pratiques
se trouve impacté le l'environnement
donc cette définition cette construction
du chemin de ce retour à l'équilibré il
doit se faire justement dans ces au sein
de ces chartes de ces concertations
territoriales pour vraiment accompagner
les différents acteurs tout en
reconnaissant leur travail puisque les
paysages français ont souvent été est
toujours quasiment dessiné par
l'activité humaine également et c'est un
patrimoine qui est que l'on que l'on
chérit tous je crois donc cette
définition à la française elle doit
vraiment s'incarner concrètement et elle
doit nous permettre je crois de
massifier 7,7 actions de protection du
territoire français à la fois terrestre
et maritime je le rappelle parce que
c'est la première fois qu'il ne sera
déchiré concilie aussi des enjeux et
associer les enjeux terrestres et
maritimes
elle doit nous permettre d'atteindre ces
objectifs qui sont ambitieux parce que
nous disposons aussi de tout un panel
d'outils de protection de mode de
gestion qui permettent de s'adapter aux
situations locales aux situations
territoriale et je pense qu'on doit
préserver aussi ses différentes nuances
différents niveaux de deux d'action et
de protection pour pouvoir nous adapter
aux situations locales aussi bien dans
la maturité des réflexions que dans les
contextes spécifiques au niveau
géographique ou ou territoriale certains
ont appelé à une homogénéisation à la
fois de c2c protection et de ses de
cette gouvernance de ces modes de
gestion moi je pense qu'il faut
justement préserver cette diversité
comme dans la diversité biologique
je pense qu'on a tout intérêt à garder
ce panel d'outils et qui il me semble
dia nous permettre de toutes façons de
faire entrer des acteurs politiques
économiques dans une démarche vertueuse
à leur rythme et à leur niveau mais en
tout cas de d'enclencher 7
cette évolution sur la question de deux
des appels à projets et des moyens qui y
sont dédiés il s'ajoute un jeu rappelle
que cette enveloppe lié à france relance
vient s'ajouter aux missions et aux
budgets au crédit que d'ailleurs la
représentation nationale a bien voulu
augmenter dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances donc c'est du plus entre
guillemets avec un défi qui est celui de
la temporalité de ce dispositif qui
demande une grande réactivité aux
acteurs et je salue leur travail en ce
moment parce que dans ce contexte de
crise qui ne nous facilite pas et on le
voit encore ce soir le travail la
concertation du fait d'une distanciation
physique qui freine un peu nos démarches
les opérateurs lead real
l'eau et b les agences de l'eau vraiment
ce moment accompagne les porteurs de
projet pour que le plus grand nombre de
projets puissent trouver une réalisation
et des moyens dans le cadre de ce plan
de relance donc plutôt qu'une inquiétude
à pouvoir accompagner les différents
territoires et à une répartition
budgétaire
je crois qu'on a un enjeu en termes
d'ingénierie sans doute on peut avoir
partout des bonnes idées il faut les
accompagner et dans le dans une
réactivité certaine je crois que c'est
vraiment le défi en tout cas ce que l'on
voit des premiers appels à projets c'est
effectivement une grande affluence et et
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé pour se saisir
de ces dispositifs ce qui est plutôt bon
signe également sur la pollution
plastique
donc nous avons vu dans le cadre du one
planet ce mythe
le président de la république engagé une
mobilisation au niveau international et
une coalition s'est créé autour de la de
la mairie méditerranée de ces enjeux
donc effectivement il va falloir le
l'accompagner au plus haut plus vite
avec donc en france un plan 0 plastique
en mer en 2025 qui doit trouver aussi
son sens
ces leviers et et sa montée en puissance
je m'y engage ce sont des réflexions que
nous avons avec les différentes
associations de protection de la nature
et les acteurs les acteurs économiques
avec à nouveau une continuité aussi
termeer qui n'est peut-être pas parfois
pas encore complètement comprise ou
ou pensez dans nos dispositifs quand
nous travaillons à l'assainissement
quand nous travaillons à des dispositifs
de réduction des déchets nous
travaillons aussi à la préservation de
la mer et des océans
donc c'est à nouveau cette cohérence
entre nos différentes politiques qui qui
se retrouvent sur ce sur ce sujet sur
donc à la question de monsieur golf sur
le frelon asiatique
ça n'est pas un petit sujet ça n'est pas
du tout un petit sujet nous avons des
outils aujourd'hui notamment en termes
de réglementation
celle qui porte sur les espèces
exotiques et piloté par le ministère et
celle qui porte sur les dangers
sanitaires piloté par le ministère de
l'agriculture
donc différents outils des moyens aussi
à déployer de police sur la détention
l'utilisation des changes et la vente de
ces de ces frelons asiatiques qui sont
évidemment interdit mais on a
malheureusement encore parfois des
mauvaises surprises
et puis des préfets qui sont aujourd'hui
habilité par arrêté préconiser des
opérations de destruction des nids
notamment sur des propriétés privées ce
qui était une attente forte de certains
acteurs pour pouvoir intervenir
rapidement par un frelon asiatique et
qui est classée 1 aussi sur la liste des
dangers sanitaires et qui donc implique
l'élaboration et le déploiement d'une
stratégie avec la filière apicole je
sais que tout le monde y est on y est
engagé il faut effectivement qu'on ne
mésestime pas ses difficultés
cette stratégie elle a permis déjà de
réduire significativement le nombre de
nids
avec un maillage effectivement fin et
régulier pour que là où nous opérons des
destructions ni se reconstitue pas à
faire vraiment un travail de dentelle à
effectuer sur le territoire
le prochain plan national en faveur des
insectes pollinisateurs qui a été lancé
conjointement par nono du ministère
comprendra plusieurs actions en ce sens
pour une meilleure coordination et des
moyens qu'ils soient massifier est
dirigée sur dans cette lutte et sur ses
interventions avec donc evelyne perron
en ligne nous avons évoqué les
difficultés de certains pnr a travaillé
on vient de parler des difficultés de
dématérialisation que nous connaissons
depuis plusieurs mois dans le dans la
crise sanitaire
effectivement j'ai bien entendu
évidemment cette cette inquiétude
maintenant elle et elle est partagée par
à peu près tous les acteurs actuellement
au niveau national dans ce calendrier
ces calendriers qui peuvent être
contraints dé concertation qui sont
difficiles à mener pour autant je crois
qu'il est de notre responsabilité de ne
pas laisser glisser complètement ses
calendriers j'avais entendu les
collectivités sur les questions de prise
de compétence à om mobilité qui était
également être très inquiète ce sont je
crois des problématiques qui se posent à
tous aujourd'hui et pour autant nous
devons nous tenir je crois à ne pas
laisser filer tous et tous ces objectifs
alors c'est quand même une difficulté
que j'ai entendus pour les chartes et
les réécritures qui devait s'opérer
d'ici à 2022 on a identifié cinq ou six
pnr je crois qu'ils sont directement
concernés avec des délais ce qui m'a
fait sourire d'ailleurs pour certains
qui étaient déjà de 24 mois on est donc
bien de l'au delà de la problématique de
la crise sanitaire
mais en tout cas donc
on a on a observé un retard moyen
prévisible de 5 à 6 mois sur les cinq
pnr concernés pour 2022 et donc par voie
d'amendement en commission spéciale sur
le projet de loi climat et résilience
nous avons rédigé rectifier un
amendement en ce sens pour donner à ces
quelques parcs naturels régionaux les
plus directement et rapidement concernés
par cette problématique
six mois de délai supplémentaire et il
appartiendra évidemment dans la navette
parlementaire aux sénateurs de de
s'exprimer sur ce point à la question de
de martine filleul sur les sur les
moyens humains et les compétences
effectivement à nouveau moi je crois aux
petits pas je crois que c'est c'est
moyen même si nous souhaiterions sans
doute tous ici qu'ils soient
démultiplier parce que nous avons une
conscience assez vives de l'urgence à
agir
je crois qu on est quand même dans des
dents dans des moyens sans précédent et
toutes proportions gardées on arrive
quand même à une prise en compte de ces
enjeux dans les politiques publiques qui
qui est une amorce le crois assez
rassurantes de ce que les questions de
préservation de la biodiversité doivent
être prises en compte au même titre que
les questions de réchauffement
climatique on sait d'ailleurs ce sont
des problématiques les traitements liés
un briquet on sait que la biodiversité
agit contre le réchauffement climatique
sa préservation en tout cas on sait que
réchauffement climatique impact la
biodiversité
donc toutes ces politiques elles doivent
être décloisonner et les moyens doivent
être sans doute étendu et étirés vers
vers les questions de préservation de la
biodiversité et la santé
environnementale d'une manière aussi
plus plus générale donc je pense que
nous avons un premier pas et surtout la
prise de conscience qui est partagée
entre les différents acteurs à nouveau
les différents niveaux de collectivités
mans en faisant ce tour de france en ce
moment je discute avec avec les élus
régionaux avec avec des conseillers
départementaux avec des maires qui
chacun à leur niveau avec les
associations commencent à inventer des
réponses et des solutions et on arrive à
rassembler nos moyens à rassembler nos
forces et je crois que c'est sûr surtout
l'enjeu en fait à partir du moment où la
prise de conscience est là où le la
parole citoyenne s'affirme pour la
préservation de ces enjeux nous pouvons
voilà raisonnablement imaginer que les
planètes s'alignent et que et que nous
parvenions enfin à prendre en compte ces
objectifs qui sont impératifs à la
question de ronan dantec sur la
stratégie foncière effectivement cette
fragmentation des espaces
l'artificialisation des sols c'est
rupture de continuité écologique ces
changements d'usagé ils sont essentiels
l'objectif zéro artificialisation quand
on parlait de marche un peu haute
il est extrêmement fort et élus
représentant les territoires vous savez
à quel point c'est un sujet d'inquiétude
aussi un pur pour pour les élus locaux
pour autant c'est un vrai défi et je
crois que qui rejoint d'ailleurs à nos
défis en termes de rénovation
énergétique peut-être plus du bâti et de
l'existant que de la construction neuve
de tous les matériaux biosourcés on a
vraiment des politiques qui se qui se
rejoignent et qui doivent qui doivent se
renforcer les unes les autres avec une
cartographie je prends le point qui doit
se précise et effectivement un décret
quand même de fin 2019 dont je n'ai plus
le détail en tête mais qui a permis de
préciser la place de la biodiversité
dans les dents laissera dette et
notamment de la préservation et la
remise en état des continuités
écologiques donc ses orientations là
elles doivent vraiment infuser dans les
dents laissera dettes et je suis sûr que
nous y serons tous vigilants a fortiori
dans la période qui s'ouvre à nous où
les politiques régionales en matière de
biodiesel l'espère seront mises à
l'honneur
avait coûté merci madame is 20h peu
d'avancé par rapport à maxime que nous
étions fixés donc c'est parfait merci
pour à la fois votre engagement
et puis la qualité des échanges entre
les collectes je remercie également et
vous même pour l'ensemble des sujets qui
ont été abordés
je crois qu'on a chacun pu me mesurer
je répète que veux tu dire des
introductions les enjeux et puis les
actions qui sont engagées mais celle qui
qui arriveront aussi au travers des
textes qu'on va pouvoir examiner dans
les semaines qui viennent merci encore
si si je peux effectivement ce que je je
vais regretter de ne pas vous en avoir
parlé mais quand je suis arrivé quand
j'ai été nommé au ministère sur ces
questions de biodiversité
nous étions en pleine convention
citoyenne sur le climat mais je me suis
posé la question de savoir si il fallait
proposer porter une convention citoyenne
qui soient dédiés à la biodiversité qui
inclurait beaucoup plus largement
évidemment les questions de forêt dos et
tout ce que nous connaissons de des
questions de biodiversité
le calendrier ne se prêtait pas au fait
de pouvoir imaginer que ces travaux
trouvent une déclinaison législative et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui faire participer
faire faire demander à des citoyens de
s'exprimer de faire des propositions
comme d'ailleurs à des élus et comme aux
parlementaires sans en trouver une
déclinaison législative 8 était
malheureux donc j'ai fait ce choix de
vraiment investir ces questions à la
stratégie nationale biodiversité et je
le dis et je le redis je vous demande si
vous voulez bien de de passer le mot et
le message est d'essayer de mobiliser
autour de vous autour de cette stratégie
nationale biodiversité on a prévu on a
décliné les outils qui doivent permettre
à tous vraiment de s'exprimer de mettre
leur pierre à l'édifice de cette
stratégie nationale biodiversité nous
trouverons
au fil du chemin les véhicules
législatifs comme c'est déjà le cas par
endroits sur le projet de loi partis
européens sur la justice
environnementale ou sur le projet de loi
climat à la marge le projet de loi 4 dès
que vous attendez j'imagine comme comme
moi donc je pense que le débat ne
pouvait pas attendre
par contre une loi en tant que tel est
une convention citoyenne entente est
dédié à ces sujets c'était pas très
réaliste en termes de calendrier
donc je vraiment je vous invite tous à
investir 7 cette réflexion sur la
stratégie nationale biodiversité
merci
[Musique]